ah ah ah só é fácil bastava que só está
a caminhar uma nova aqui a minha
campanha que como vocês podem ter para
já e o dobro da última e continuei fazer
usando só folhas a4 emissora prazer de
estar aqui eu usei embora campolina a 2
quando eu comprei por 30 cm uma autoria
a esconder tempo para que a e da volta
do real é um qualquer coisa não deve
fugir disso a senhora falar o preço a e
pronto com a espanha é muito resistente
bateu a gol também protestei porque eu
fiz aqui uma estrutura especial talentos
por cinco vezes na última greve vai
ficar mais difícil mas vocês podem usar
fita crepe a cair ou fita cola porque
está com uma cara feia está aqui duas
coisas mas é no total vai dar uma
proteína ainda vai aprontar toca a
segunda história ainda vai sobrar um
pouco da sua história
agora vamos a portugal depois de fazer
equipado já pode notar como eu com bola
então está a começar e sol
primeiro vão ter que passar cinco linhas
em paralelo a uma distância de dois
centímetros entre elas como é que vocês
vão fazer isso por muito simples ao
marcar 2 468 em 10 cêntimos lada kalina
e mesmo para o outro
depois é só conectar os pontos usando
uma régua então tá acima dele começou
aqui fazer depois de finalizar essa
parte é só cortar na última linha
estou aqui marcar ajudar no hospital
badim com uma lâmina vai para duas
faixas e vai sobrar uma mais que é para
conectar as duas lâminas vocês vão
dobrar moda aqui que duas duas faixas
por um lado em três faixas para o outro
importante você juntar em banho-maria
aquele feito de lâmina afiada pode
encarar bem vamos brincar
a terceira faixa do lado tem três faixas
a cair virada para a queda das que
trabalham muito grave
só desta maneira que vocês vão conseguir
conectar as duas amigas ficar tudo muito
bem e muito importante
enquanto aqui para conectar as lâminas
eu vou usar uma cola é rápida mas se
vocês não tiverem podem usar e fita
crepe de tipos de crepes consegue usar
em cola é só para não ser esta pode ser
outra qualquer
é porque vocês usarem cola não se vai
notar as conexões até aí vai ficar mais
bonita e agora como é óbvio
vocês vão ter que pressionar para
especular agora vão pressionar na parte
que estava em cada cenário que vai
encarar os lados pronto
a média da lâmina
[Música]
a mina é quem tem várias linhas de
orientação à frente
meu nome é mais fácil foi escrito por aí
que se empreenda tem um pequeno integral
e dois lados iguais é enquanto só quero
quadrado por tirar essa faixa que até
aqui vai ser preciso que um tubinho
inicial caiu aqui num dos cantos da casa
da mãe e depois vai conseguir saber
dentro de vocês ainda vão cortar fora de
casa mas é preciso daqui mas nunca vi
alguma coisa vocês podem fazer depois
fazer tudo em grande parte que sobrou
também para fazer o tucano de mais
pequeno isso porque os dois
vamos ter um tubinho com comprimento
superior o tamanho da lâmina e culpar
sobrar vou fazer o fundo da espada seja
a parte que vamos chegar às para depois
de inflarem vão ter que entender com
alguma coisa para não dizer lário
anterior lei que nunca em toronto mas
francis não importa quem vai ficar na
parte interna das para depois aqui
decolar é só cortar as extremidades
agora vamos juntar nos dois domingos por
isso porque um cliente cola na
extremidade
acho que no poder por muita cola mesma
notícia para ficar bem resistente
introduzir convém contudo nenhum quem
tenham dentro mais pequeno grande caiu
para conseguir introduzir lá dentro
depois é só terá o chefe escola e agora
só em fazer parte da frente da lâmina
vocês não ficarem muito e agora eu tenho
muita cola nessa altura a mais
ao brincar em cada escola
depois volta atrás e vai conectar melhor
domina e toca mais tenta cortar até
escolar pois no final podem tirar
processo para não ficar foi consagrada
continuar a usar uma cartolina preta no
mesmo tamanho que vai fazer uma faixa
para fazer a proteção do cunho seja uma
coisa ou outra onda ou retangular ou
enfeitada
vou testar a linha daquela parte fica no
programa decolar com lâmina é cortar e
depois vou cursar da espessura da
proteção do corpo
agora a água invadir o tamanho que vocês
querem ou porque sinto que estou a fazer
que promovam pequena minha mãe muito
grande mas quando estou a fazer com que
essa máquina porque é provável que você
tenha uma mais pequena que minha coisa é
muito grande
aí pronto foi muito branda assim que
chegar ao final da fita chegarem ao fim
mais uma obra é também cortar e e acesso
a gente não pode ficar teclado a mãe tem
que ficar mesmo assim quando acabar você
exporta e pronta e vamos prender isso
será que cola através de atenção como é
que eu vou pôr a cola não podem por um
centro porém por só nas bordas
por que vocês quiserem no centro depois
vai atrapalhar a um processo que irá
cair na parte onde temos que fazer um
orifício nesta proteção e conseguimos
controlar a minha régua e traçar duas
finais a cair
por outro lado na prestação dessas digo
nós vamos ter o centro da nossa terra
centralizado e fazer o melhor e agora
vai em paralelo avançando até chegar ao
ponto e assim vamos ter uma linha
paralela com as bordas
agora vejam que a nossa lâmina é um
hexágono vamos manter aqui a largura
como é um hexágono nós temos que
desenhar um hexágono aqui vocês vão ver
com outra
mais ou menos a próxima da cae vai
juntar em fazer o exame
e pronto está disposto num camelô lâmina
vocês vão estar no green corta mais um
campo mais um crime até entrar agora
vamos usar que os dados e tirar a parte
que eu disney
vocês vão portanto vai ter um cuidado
para não ficarem mesmo a cair só fiz
aqui o crime mas pode virar em cima da
outra coisa pra não estragar alimentava
de fundo
o pessoal já está já teria tudo e agora
vou introduzir aqui na lâmina não faz
mal que estavam com ele entrar assim a
banda realmente vai ficar mais estava a
cair e agora pra não deixar aqui um 102
centímetros dentro com vocês quiserem
agora vou marcar aqui um dinheiro é
parte do punho a parte que eu quero
agarrar a cair vou deixar a minha mão
estas palavras público tem um filho
pequeno e mandando como eu podem deixar
um sentindo bem e agora vou cortar outra
faixa para enrolar a volta do público
vai ficar mais um moço mais bonita é
difícil manusear as portas para que mais
um pedaço querido
isto é sobre a pequena que eu fiz com a
extremidade a e agora vou cravar no
punho
podem ver agora porque aumentar o volume
porque vejo que está desproporcional lá
para todo mundo na frente com a parte do
mundo traz no punho a cair até ficar
mais ou menos proporcional à escola país
não sair
é importante que vocês façam isso as
pessoas ficaram um pouco da espada num
ano vai ser nada se ela cai vai ganhar
muito e vocês não vão ter muito controle
ela vai ficar muito flácida e agora
propõe no colo uma linha e começarem a
voar fita começar cada vez pois ajudam
caí com a santa vossa maldito é um
público pequeno para o irmão de outro
jeito é deixar nos 1 161 escolher um
animal é grande mas quando comecei a 1
deu pessoas mais novas e eu deixei 800
enquanto união económica que tem só pra
que fixará lâmina e depois não por outro
lado também mais um caminho só pra ir
embora quando canta rápida rápida quanto
é sempre uma coisa só revelar por
colocar lá pô eu espero que não
vocês quiserem até podem pôr outra coisa
parecida qualquer coisa e corpo vai
ficar mais bonita
agora é só dar chutão pelo toque
enquanto só ficou muito feliz só é
chamado assim as cartas do estado em
busca de fazer e pronto estava mesmo
joinha favorite isso se inscreva no
canal ainda não não foram inscritos a e
pronto devem deixar uns comentários
propostas de projetos pra mim foi o caso
dessa história e está obrigado de estilo
e até a próxima